España es un país de tradición
monárquica desde hace más de 550 años
sin embargo en 1873 y 1931 se
proclamaron la primera y Segunda
República Española respectivamente cada
14 de abril en el aniversario de la
última proclamación republicana cientos
de Defensores de este sistema de
gobierno salen a las calles de la nación
aquí estamos reivindicando que el rey no
tenía que reinar en este país no elijo
ni el padre porque cuando se hizo la
constitución en el 78 tenía que haber
habido un referéndum monarquía o
República creemos que ha llegado el
momento de que la ciudadanía pueda
decidir qué tipo de jefe de estado
quiere tener y sobre todo poderlo votar
y no como ahora que no tenemos
posibilidad de votar el jefe del Estado
hombre para empezar porque la
institución
monarquía solo nos cuesta y aparte de
que creo o sea Considero que se ríen de
nosotros en nuestra propia cara Aunque
haya españoles que lo defienden en la
actualidad la monarquía sigue teniendo
buena aceptación Una institución que se
lleva 8,4 millones de euros del
presupuesto general del estado cada año
y que se ha visto salpicada en los
últimos años por los casos de corrupción
y blanqueo de capitales del rey emérito
Juan Carlos I que desde 2020 viven
emiratos árabes Unidos
buena no puedo opinar buena
del otro rey Juan Carlos lo primero
bueno y lo último catastrófico según el
centro de investigaciones sociológicas
la monarquía está dentro de los últimos
puestos de preocupaciones principales de
los españoles esto frente a la crisis
económica o al paro sin embargo en una
encuesta hecha por medios independientes
un 39% de la población si votaría a
favor de cambiar el sistema hacia una
República en caso de celebrarse un
referendo frente al 31% que se quedaría
con el sistema monárquico actual